can you be weak but strong at the same
time can you be weak but strong at the
same time yes you can you can't because
you can be for instance you can be
physically strong but at the same time
you could be mentally weak or you could
be the opposite you could be mentally
weak but at the same time physically
strong and I would love to be able to
put a priority on one of those and I
know I've said before that knowledge is
the most important thing but the reality
is if you don't have the strength or
actually the health to back that up or
even to function as a human being
physically then your knowledge and your
mental strength doesn't really even
matter
so that comes into play and being big
and strong is also totally useless if
you're mentally weak and you quit now
being mentally strong should actually
lead you to being physically strong
because if you are mentally strong then
you can work and train to become
physically strong but if you're mentally
weak then you will not hold the line on
the good food and the good workouts and
you won't get physically strong or
healthy so can you be weak and strong at
the same time yes but I say be strong
train your physical strength and
exercise your mental strength by doing
the right things the hard things the
things you know you're supposed to do
do them and be as strong as you can
mentally physically and emotionally for
yourself for your team for your family
hold the line and be strong